Did you feel as though you were treated
any differently than say like a Jew who
may have been walking down the street?
No, at all. I think I was uh lucky. I
felt I've been treated as a celebrity
treatment. People were happy I'm being
there. It's heartbreaking seeing so many
people dying. But that's where
unfortunately um I from my opinion I
don't think it's a genocide. In my
country, you know what they say, instead
of your mom giving birth to you, if she
done a big fat fart, it would have been
better for humanity. I promise
you. Salamkum. Guys, before you watch
the video guys, check out this new game
me and my kids have been playing.
Alhamdulillah. It's called Quran Quest
with Ali and Sumea. It's like Subway
Surfers, but it teaches the meaning of
the Quran. So, now you can play a game
that is fun, and you can learn Arabic at
the same time with your kids. You can
learn over 1,400 words from the Quran
just by playing this game.
Alhamdulillah. What are you waiting for?
Click the link in the description to
download and start playing and learning
for free. Brothers and sisters, download
it now.
Inshallaham. Welcome to brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Get ready to
spit on the screen. Not at me. Um, get
ready to spit somewhere, brothers and
sisters, because what you're going to
see is going to make you so sick to your
stomach. I'll be honest, I'm holding
back spitting in the camera. For
example, here is an individual called
Fatim Fatima Al-Hari. Yes. And she's
speaking to a Zionist, which I found out
later that I was he must be neutral, you
know. No, no, no, no, no. She's invited
by a Zionist, pro Zionist, brother and
sisters, Cam Higgby or something for
that matter who makes it very clear.
Before this, I was thinking maybe this
guy just seems somewhat neutral. Na da
da. Let's watch for oursel where our
Arab sister in hijab in hijab doesn't
know what the hijab is. The heart of the
hijab is dead. Yes. No shame, no ha. Hay
is not just your modesty and covering
your private parts. You are the one of
the most shameless woman I have seen in
my life. and you are covered. How about
that? Let's watch it for oursel in you
will understand why I'm so disgusted.
Does Israel treat um Muslim religious
sites? Okay. Um are they wellkept? Do
they protect them? Do they allow Muslims
to go visit their religious sites? How
wellmaintained are they? Um I did visit
Alaka mosque and I prayed and and it's
an honor for any Muslim to go pray there
and it's a dream for so many Muslims. So
I've always thought that I won't be
welcomed by the Israelis that they won't
let me pray there. But uh I went there,
no one stopped me and they didn't know
I'm Bahraini or any other nationality.
They saw me as Muslim woman because of
the headscarf. Uh no one stopped me. I I
entered mosque and I got to pray and and
I saw it as a beautiful place and it was
filled with m Muslims and Palestinians.
I got to talk to so many of them uh at
Alaka mosque and I think it's wellkept
and and I saw uh so many security
personnel uh taking care of that area. I
felt safe that day in and mosque. And
when you were in Israel um I assume that
you were wearing your headscarf and you
appeared to be a Muslim Arab woman. Did
you feel as though you were treated any
differently than say like a Jew who may
have been walking down the street? No,
at all. I think I was uh lucky. I felt
I've been treated as a celebrity
treatment. People were happy I'm being
there. They they they told me a complete
stranger told me they were happy seeing
an Arab from the neighboring countries
in Israel and uh I've never felt like I
treated differently in a bad way.
Amazing. Amazing. Oh my god. Absolutely
amazing she got there. you know, not
that she's um, you know, works for an
organization that's um has connections
to the Abraham Accords, you know, that
they're not holding hands with them. No,
no, no, no, no. Not that she's an
official that went there, you know,
she's acting like she went there, you
know, just like a tourist, whatever it
is for that matter. Most likely, no way
she did cuz the Israelis, the Zionist
would never treat like that. This
Zionist that is sitting in front of the
scumbag who has is is an Islamophobe
himself, as you can see, is an
Islamophobe. He probably despises you.
The only reason you're sitting there is
because you know like the prophetam said
you know okay and Allah says in the
Quran you know the people of the book
they will never be pleased with you
until you follow their what pathway and
this is exactly what the prophetam
prophesies that the Muslims will follow
them handspan by handspan that if they
enter a lizard's home they will follow
them and this shameless hijabi fatim
shame on you you are talking like yeah I
went there and they treated me well and
da da da really is that how the
Palestinians are treated
Is that second class citizens? Is that
how they treated? Yeah. They can't even
go through certain places. Yes. They are
being massacred. The whole of Israel,
Zionist. These scums are doing what?
Yes. Doing what? Treating them. How?
Blowing them into pieces. Men, women,
children, kids, babies. And you are sat
there with this pro-Zionist scum. Dirt.
And you are there. Oh yeah, I went
there. They treat me like a celebrity.
You fake fake. You are a fake fake
Muslim woman. You fake hijab. And by the
way, she's not Muslim. Yes, you are
fake. You make me sick. You make me
sick. Let's carry on. That's awesome.
Um, do you have any insights on like
there's a lot of claims right now of
genocide? What is your view on that? Do
you think that a genocide is happening
in Gaza or in the West Bank?
Unfortunately, the scene in Gaza is
heartbreaking. No one wants to see
anyone being killed or died because of
war. uh so many innocent people paying
the price that they don't want to pay.
Uh people want to live normal lives.
They want to have jobs, dreams,
families. Uh and it breaks my heart
seeing those people dying, those
families, those children. But um
unfortunately, the situation is very
complicated for both sides, for the
Palestinians, innocent Palestinians in
Gaza and for the Israelis also. Um um
it's heartbreaking seeing so many people
dying, but that's where unfortunately um
I from my opinion I don't think it's a
genocide, but that's the the the price
that the innocent people pays for for
war. And my my wish is of course I I
want this to stop. I don't want anyone
to gets killed or dies because of this.
Uh Palestinians and Israelis, the
innocent people. And you see that guys
that pro-sionist she's sitting in front
of now I am obviously like I just want
to um how can I
explain she goes it's not a genocide
there are people there are people
scholars yes there are people who have
come out from all of life call it a
genocide all for
non-Muslims man women in many skirts
miniskirt many bikinis you will look at
them and say you look at this woman with
a hijab And you look at the woman who's
in a bikini in a mini skirt who are
coming and pro Palestinian wall
non-Muslim woman Allahh mercy. Yes. Not
for just a Muslim. Yes. Okay. This woman
doesn't understand. Cannot come close to
their to their um to their just justice.
Yes. That's why said Allah will give
victory to the non-Muslims because of
their justice. Yes. Over the Muslims.
Okay. If you're unjust, Allah would
humiliate. doesn't keep wearing a
motorbike, helmet, whatever you wear
means nothing. You'll have women in you
look at and you'll question her the way
she dresses it in
more that woman has more hay more shame
not only dressings but more shame more
dignity more more uh what you want to
call it more justice in her than this
woman who's dressed up from head to toe
mashallah you are a shameless
woman it's not a genocide and that
proionist scum is listening there he's
does he even condemn does condemn the
Israeli government. Nothing is just
listening. Yeah. Let this insecure,
infer, this one with the inferiority
complex over us white people, you know,
let her just talk for us. You puppet.
You are a puppet. You have been bought.
You've been bought for a few coins and
Allah will ask you questions on your
Makayama. Allah subhanana wa ta'ala will
humiliate you in your makayama. Yes,
it's not a genocide. Yeah. And let's
just get to know a bit about this woman.
Who is this woman by the way? Yeah.
Let's just go to Yes. Okay. Fatim Fatima
Alh Hari was born in 1991 or 1992. In my
country, you know what they say? Instead
of your mom giving birth to you, if
she'd done a big fat fart, it would have
been better for humanity. I promise you,
if she passed wind was better than
giving birth to a woman like you is a
Bahrain author, peace activist, former
civilian servant, and the director of
Gulf affairs at the UAE based
organization Sharaka and the CEO of an
organization Bahrain branch. She's also
one young world European Commission
peace ambassador. peace ambassador.
Okay, so uh this this book gets really
interesting. Let's go to a little
personal life. Okay. Um and Hari wears a
hijab. She says that she has lost
friends due to her efforts to make peace
with Israelis. Your friends
wall whoever boycotted you.
Alhamdulillah. Wall. Alhamdulillah. You
shameless woman. In 2022, she said that
uh she began posting about the Holocaust
on social media in response to
widespread Holocaust denial in the Arab
world. Widespread. I I let me be honest
with you. This is in bull crap that
there's widespread denial. Why don't you
talk about the Holocaust that's
happening now? Why don't you talk about
the Holocaust happening now? There is
Jews who were in their forefathers were
in the Holocaust that come and speak out
against what Israel is doing. Jews, real
Jews, yes, not Zionists who are coming
to speak out against it. But no uh
recognition and honors. In 2002, Alhabi
was named one young world European
Commission peace ambassador. The program
supports young people working to prevent
counterviolent extremism in communities.
That year she was also a scholar in
residence at Oxford University. Yeah.
But check this out guys. Watch this now.
Yeah. Her uh this is where it gets
interesting. She has written five novels
in Arabic uh about women's issues in
Bahrain society which is incor which
which incorporate love stories as they
deal with issues such as gender
equality, women empowerment and mental
health. And why you not talking about
the women that have been massacred in
Palestine by your Israeli? It's not a
genocide. Yeah. Why you not talking
about the Fatima Hari? Yes. You fat
shameless. Yes. Why don't you talk about
that? What happened to empowerment?
Woman empowerment. Yes. Only woman
empowerment when it comes to the
different stuff. Why don't you talk
about that? Wall. Wall. Brothers and
sisters, I got nothing else to say.
Wall. Name and shame this woman. Name
and shame this shameless woman. Wall. I
am ashamed to share a same religion with
you. Shame on you guys. If you know who
she is, wahi, brothers and sisters, name
and shame her. name and shame her. Okay,
watch this next bit now. Let's watch the
next bit. Last question. And if you
don't have an answer, it's totally fine.
We just chop the end off. Um, what do
you think is to be done with Hamas? Do
you have any ideas of like what the
solution is to sort of remedying the
situation, making peace, things like
that? I think the best solution is for
Hamas to to care about Palestinians, uh,
to let them live their life. I think
disarm and release the hostages. uh they
deserve to go back home and uh I think
this is the best solution for both the
Israelis and for the Palestinians. Uh I
saw so many videos Palestinians saying
we want a ceasefire. We don't want this.
So many people are dying. They they just
want to live and they deserve that.
Yeah. Now put Hamas to aside. Yes. The
UN has made it very clear that the
resistance has every right to defend
itself armed on the resistance. Yes. But
no no no no. I mean you like the fact
that they don't even speak about the 50
to
100,000 people
massacred fat har you make me
sick if you're watching this video you
make me sick may Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala deal with you you away from your
kids we don't want the same things
happen you are a sick person you are a
shameful person and you will go down in
history as a shame shameful person.
Shame on
you. May Allah deal with you. All I'm
going to say is may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala make you wake up in horrors. May
Allah subhanahu wa subhana wa tala make
you suffer just as those Palestinian
women and children are being massacred
and not don't know when the bombs are
going to drop. May you have the same
anxiety as them. May Allah subhana wa
tala deal with you. That's what I'm
going to say. Shame on you. You are a
sellout. You've been bought out,
brothers and sisters.
That's all I have to say.